[Musique]
c'est incroyable
c'est avant
que tu
tous
boss
jacky
même principe physique à bord de la
station spatiale c'est aussi le même
principe physique à bord d une cabine
d'ascenseur qui trouve
250e étage pour ça que ça dure que
trente secondes ça permettrait
plein d'expériences scientifiques
[Musique]
je suis vidéo grâce à de la chaîne
youtube de retirer le dgi et on est ici
avec brut pour aller faire un vol zéro-g
occasion qui est derrière moi est un
véritable laboratoire dans lequel les
chercheurs peuvent venir amener leurs
expériences et tester des hypothèses
dans des conditions de pesanteurs qui
est plus faible que sur la planète
donc là sur ce vol il y aura
principalement des chercheurs et un vol
vraiment à but scientifique et on va
faire le brief sécu parce que le vol
dans un projet c'est demain
vous voulez tout cela
je dis d'accord ont déjà avant tout les
paraboles nom fera un petit rappel et
vous demander de fermer vos poches
changer les bases des tournevis lui les
petits outils que vous pourriez d'avoir
pour éviter que ils se mettent à voler
dans cabinet sce vole la était utilisé
par la nasa pour commencer
l'entraînement des astronautes et
notamment ceux qui sont allés sur la
lune les vols paraboliques scientifique
ils ont commencé dans les années 80
or le but c'était tout simplement
d'embarquer des expériences
scientifiques manière tout à fait
comparable à ce qui se passe en orbite
dans la station spatiale internationale
ouvert à tous ce passe bien et pas bien
il est sage sauf que là la sangle avait
fini par glisser et à la fin la veille à
nager un petit pic négatif et voyez
c'est le résultat il est immédiat pic
négatif on part au plafond le plafond
really à deux mètres vingt deux mètres
heureusement il y avait le matelas qui
était en dessous donc voilà on veut
surtout pas ça on vous demande d'être
vraiment sérieux et d'être sécurisés en
fait un groupe briefing de sécurité pour
savoir quelle est la conduite à tenir
quand même matériel a accepté à voir on
se retrouve en apesanteur pendant 20
secondes après on subit deux fois
pendant deux fois vingt secondes qui me
prépare un petit peu à l'avance à ce
qu'on va vivre pour qu'on soit le moins
son prix possible qu'on puisse profiter
au mieux de l'espace
[Musique]
non
nos carnets dans l'enceinte de recherche
du vol zéro-g ici c'est là où il ya
toutes les expérimentations
scientifiques qui sont faites
elles ont chacune leur espace les
chercheurs ils seront tenus par des
sangles tout le monde doit être tenu par
les sens mais ici ce sinon les gens vont
tomber les uns sur les autres avec des
paraboles limur le sol et le plafond ou
et et matelassée pour amortir les chocs
parce que ben on a le corps qui monte
naturellement on a plus aucun contrôle
sur le mouvement toutes les expériences
scientifiques ont été matelassé au cas
où il ya des trucs qui tombe dessus faut
le protéger et ce qui est vraiment
intéressant dans cet outil de recherche
finalement c'est un avion de recherche
c'est que ils aident à préparer le futur
de l'exploration spatiale
il a beaucoup d'expérience qui sont
faites ici qui ont un lien direct avec
la station spatiale internationale
les préparatifs sont terminés on a pu
voir un peu quel type d'expérience il y
aurait demain en apesanteur
ça va être vraiment vraiment hyper
intéressant et on est tous très très
excité donc on va aller se coucher à
cette eau parce que bon on décolle à 7
heures demain aussi pour se faire piquer
ouais maggie grace est libre vous avez
déjà volé non première fois j'ai fait la
dose de base standard pour les hommes
cette injection c'était de la
scopolamine donc c'est un sédatif qui
permet de ne pas ressentir de nausées
parce que le problème de l'avion c'est
que notre cerveau va voir quelque chose
et notre corps va ressentir quelque
chose de complètement différent
et ces deux informations contradictoires
peuvent vraiment provoquer une tension
est extrême mal à l'aise thériault juste
pour diminuer l'activité et la
sensibilité de notre estime
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
donc l'armée à dix minutes de la
première parabole
les chercheurs sont en train d'allumer
leur expérience
ce qui va se passer c'est que dans dix
minutes l'avion va prendre beaucoup de
vitesse
il a commencé à
et on va gagner vrai 200 mètres
d'altitude pour arriver au sommet de la
barre donne là on va supporter
restos
défaits à fond
[Musique]
on
je
what i
ces lentilles
[Applaudissements]
howard
une fois sans retard
l'action
le
haïti
faire tout
ça s'est passé avant
toutes essences sont courants
évidemment mon visage qui valait 100
seul
voilà c'est parti on monte on
vitesse ma voix
des formations sur mon visage s'était
dit pour l'usager a tiré vers le bas
de quoi plus quasiment que d'habitude et
là bientôt on va arriver au sommet de la
parabole aujourd'hui à parabole mon nez
on a peu entendu
le ch'ti avec ça y est à chaque fois
c'est un bon mois à chaque fois c'est
vraiment un phénomène incroyable et on
se retrouve vraiment pour perte totale
une sensation
je suis de ton envers façon
alors les endroits il n'y a plus aucune
victime
sissoko
[Musique]
on recrée à l'intérieur l'impesanteur
tels que tout va flotter exactement
c'est le même principe physique à bord
de la station spatiale
c'est aussi de même principe physique à
bord d une cabine d'ascenseur qui
tomberait du 250e étage donc par rapport
à la cabine
on flotte mais l'avion lui pendant cette
trajectoire au bout d'un moment elle va
te descendre vont reprendre une
trajectoire normale
on sait que ça dure que trente secondes
ça permet de réaliser plein
d'expériences scientifiques ne soit
parce que tout est fermé mais on est en
train de cabrer les pilotes sont en
train de cabrer tirer sur le manche
l'avion pour une trajectoire très
vertical l'a ensuite dauger de deux fois
le poids de notre corps est ensuite une
fois qu'on va peut-être arriver vraiment
le nez en l'air on va injecter l'avion
sur la parabole est là tout va commencer
à affronter
c'est maintenant que ça se passe et là
tout d'école alors normalement si c'est
zéro on reste exactement au même niveau
si c'est un peu positif au monde si
c'est un peu négatif on descend et là
c'est exactement la même chose que dans
la station spatiale
sauf que ça dure que trente secondes là
l'avion redescend la tête vers le bas et
on va reprendre une trajectoire exemptes
aller à ce moment là quand on reprendra
injectera horizontale qu'on tire sur le
manche c'est comme en voltige
on prend un peu des jets ont écrasé par
deux fois notre poids pendant cette
manoeuvre jusqu'à ce que ça soit terminé
pour prenne un vol horizontal et là on
est dans les conditions pour recommencer
une nouvelle
c'est exactement les mêmes sensations
par la différence c'est qu'ici ça dure
que trente secondes la différence aussi
c'est ici malgré que le pilotage très
précis des parfois un peu positif au
négatif donc ça à monter descendre dans
la station pendant six mois
ça bouge pas du tour décalée sur le zéro
un prix qu'il faut savoir c'est que le
mal de l'espace où le sound adaptation
spéciale en anglais est principalement
due aux systèmes destinés aux nerfs de
l'oreille interne qui est complètement
désorienté en fait on à 3,2 me les
canaux qui nous donne après des
informations sur l'orientation de la
tête et on a aussi des otolithes donc
céder petit à petit
qui a tenu tête indique la direction de
sens
la vérité
c'est là
[Musique]
cette indépendance et l'hypertension hta
deux niveaux le premier c
et sensorielle extrêmement intéressant
de ressentir toute une nouvelle gamme de
choses de sensations en fait notre
oreille interne n'a jamais vécu ça c'est
vraiment fou un avion peut être
transformé en laboratoire pour pouvoir
donner les différences qui font de la
micropesanteur donc c'est vraiment à
tous les sens à tous les aspects c'est
un missile a response
[Musique]